one more drink one more
drink you know in the morning
for sure we gonna stink one more
round one more round
it's
this is what we do catch up for a few
we'll riff and talk some [ __ ] and then
we'll sleep till two
[Music]
hey folks all right we're here we're
hungover
we're disheveled we're queer i'm
hungover
[Music]
this is the only show in history where
being hungover is is appropriate
and and kind of normal
yeah it's one of those we're doing a day
pod today day drinking pod and i i was
like [ __ ] i gotta drink something i
didn't
touch last night and i touched a lot
yeah
you know what i mean you ever ever like
looking like what can i i tequila
i did gin i did uh vodka kind of like i
gotta
so i'm going i'm going with a light i'm
doing a little uh
compari it's a big it's a pint glass
version of it but it's a campari
campari soda simple very effeminate
drink but
yeah i'm trying to ease my my way back
in it's 4 p.m you know
that's a good that's like uh what's that
guys like a chas bono of drinks it's
just
easing in you're transitioning easily
slowly in
campari is like a liqueur almost right
it's not actually a liquor
yeah it's like 20 it's not it's not
super strong but it gives you that it
gives you enough to get in i like to
ease my way back in
it's like bitters i think bitters has
just a touch of
jizz in it just a little bit alcohol
yeah a little bit of juice
that's the way to do it like sprite with
some gingers and you're back in but
you're not shit-faced
i love it how about you what are you
doing i'm taking it easy and i'm in i'm
in austin so i've been
boozing i've been drinking drinking
tequila we get eating queso i've been
[ __ ] blood
this town is just alive and bubbling up
at the seams and uh so i got a nice uh
uh nice light medello here you know a
nice mexican beer
probably one of my favorites with the
gold i hate modelo but i love
especially oh you don't like the negro
modelo i mean i like it but
it's just black and dark and heavy this
is just light and airy
yeah um yeah well classic
but they were saying the same [ __ ] at
the capitol anyway
yeah it's too dark out there we got to
make some changes
but yeah uh yeah that's good yeah this
is this is perfect actually i was like
walking i'm taking a
nice little stroll in the rain as it's
coming down hard on me
got a little got a little uh massage
help the old neck the neck will go out
trigger point massage therapy man it's
painful but it really it gets the job
done
it it does it releases toxins there's
all these studies that like everybody
should be getting massage i just
my dumb childhood my evil brain i cannot
walk into a
rub and tug i can do but a massage i
can't do
i feel guilty just look at it like it's
like
like a doctor look at it like it's a
like you know have you ever been to a
chiropractor
no never oh man i've done that it's it's
some of them i feel like do nothing yes
i can crack my own back i get on a chair
i do this i do the twist move
i saw one guy once and he was just like
standing in the corner and he just like
ran into me and like and like
i was just like what the [ __ ] hurt and
he was like well i gotta you know i
gotta level it out and he was like oh
all right you just [ __ ] it was like
it was like a
defensive end running into me i'm like
it just [ __ ] hurt
yeah i got cte now you you [ __ ] what
what the hell
i mean i don't know a chiropractor is
that expensive it seems like such a
weird game
they pop your elbow and you give them 50
grand there's this one dude in l.a that
saved my ass he's a good chiropractor dr
cole in uh culver city he's jacked
he was oh studio city not culver city
not not close at all but uh yeah he was
like he called you don't trust him
because he came in with like a
sleeveless shirt he was shredded
he called me bro and you're like what
doctor what doctor talks like this you
know
dr chad his name is actually doug
oh doug is perfect yeah but he was
he's incredible dude he saved my i've
sent people them and they're like yeah
that guy is a game changer
all right i mean hey look acupuncture i
don't i still don't know if i believe in
yet
i'm still on the fence on cbd but people
swear by chiropractors so maybe i'll try
acupuncture
acupuncture yeah they'll give you
they'll do the cupping on you yeah all
the athletes do that [ __ ] and then i'm
kind of like what am i doing that i need
the same treatment as michael phelps
maybe it's like i'm just
smoking weed i guess it's about the only
similarity yeah
yeah dude it i i don't know how athletes
do it i don't know how they
play i mean i know they have access to
the best
healing and doctors and all that stuff
but you're still
i know they're on a special jet usually
but it's still
they're still seven feet they're still
just played 40 minutes yeah and
it's physical and then you land and you
got to play i mean that's it's [ __ ]
hard man
it's a nightmare then you got a train on
top of that and
didn't didn't some football player just
shoot his wife and his kids and himself
yeah
i i don't know if he had ct i didn't see
that yet but yeah he's i mean that's
what's going down that was like aaron
hernandez man he yeah
advanced cte junior sayo uh
he told himself ct so you got to look
into that [ __ ] is bob i
i don't know enough about it but i do
feel like based on this is probably
might come off as ignorant but i feel
like mma must be
much safer than the nfl because it's
every every few months you're fighting
like you train
but if you're an nfl the thing if you're
an offensive lineman all you do is
like bat crack helmets all day exactly
all day and you in the training in the
game you hear that smash and at least
with ufc they stop it you've never seen
a rep come in and go all right he's
tackled
you got him you know it's it's just
piled up by eight guys you know they're
all 300 pounds
and yeah the cool thing about ufc is
they at least will say it like
i gotta stop fighting because i want to
keep my brain i got kids i want to hang
out with my kids
so they'll actually admit it like yeah
i'm getting punched in the face this is
bad news
but sometimes you see him man like i
don't know if holyfield was going to
fight again i remember i had holyfield
when i had a sports show on my show and
like this dude
fought professionally for like 30 years
crazy
that i can't imagine what that and he
was a bruiser that was his whole thing
he's like i'm a [ __ ] i'm i'm the guy
who's going to stay in it
right right and he did did he hear you
he only has one ear
he was i think he was probably i think
it was like a little
a little slow but he also
he we'd make jokes i remember we opened
it with stavros
and stop i'm like we have a new opponent
who you've never faced and stavos just
ran in and ripped his shirt off
and was like ah and he was laughing he
was be he was i mean
he was being silly with us too so that's
great but he's such a legend you're just
kind of like oh man it's like i'm in the
presence of like one of the best
ever of course you just feel that they
just walk with that you know he beat
tyson i mean what
what kind of mind state you have to be
in to see mike tyson and go oh i can
beat that guy
that is insane and he beat him
yeah well tyson was so he had that
stretch
out of the gate yes he's like five
eight five seven she's a tank ah and
that he's got the
that torque i mean yeah terrifying human
being
so scary brown what uh
where so you're in austin how are the
shows
oh my god i can't even i can't even get
into it because it they've been so great
we had all we sold out every show we
added a show sunday it just sold out
again it's at 25
capacity which is not not a big brag
here but uh
it still feels good but there's demand
there's demand and that excitement
is yeah and you feel that from the crowd
like i was at the seller all weekend i'm
like oh i feel
an energy man yes yes and and i gotta
say if this is what 25
of the paramount theater feels like i
can't even imagine that 100 it's got to
be just
booming laughs i opened for his ease
there once and it was pretty it was
pretty special it's pretty damn oh yeah
yeah great it's one of those cool cities
where like you're on sixth street you're
on congress everybody's up and at them
there's a guy on stilts as a drag queen
on a unicycle and a frat guy puking
and then you go in the theater and it's
from 1915 the marx
brothers charlie chaplin have been here
and it's beautiful and ornate
and you're like wow right outside is
like a guy doing heroin
it's so funny you just see like frat
douches and then you walk in there like
elvis [ __ ] someone in this broom closet
right here they've got all this
weird history exactly i know and it's so
pretty in there
it's uh it's cool how showbiz works then
you just you do these
shows you get these applauses you high
five everybody go outside and then you
become
just as degenerate as the other guys
it is pretty weird man you're up there
and it's like you feel like man this is
so
kind of i don't want to say dignified
but you're in a theater there's
something kind of
there's something kind of dignified
about that and then you then you're like
oh yeah but i'm not
a theater person right right yeah
there's a chandelier a box seat i'm like
i'm not that guy yeah i got a mixed
drink in the in the in the green room
and i just took a [ __ ] a diarrhea
i'm talking about my dick on stage but
it is there is an eloquence to it
i remember when ray romano did i think
he did radio city or some
great new york theater i forgot which
one but he had a line where he's like i
think i'm the first person to ever say
anal leakage in here
i remember that yes yeah that was a
great because
he wasn't the seller he was the seller
all weekend too wow
nicest comic i'm hands down nicest comic
i've ever met
i'm on stage upstairs as the upstairs
and the downstairs of the cellar and i
hear
this booming this booming applause to
the point that it kind of disrupted my
set for a second
and i was like you know i'm a little
upset i didn't get that
uh that ovation and everyone starts
cheering like crazy to like you know
being
fond so they're trying to outdo
downstairs and then i get off stage i go
downstairs
rock and chapelle on stage together oh
man that's amazing yeah wow
boy we're back baby it's pretty cool man
it was a fun night cellar was hopping
and then of course you know
i'm at you forget that they the hookup
the way they hook it up alcohol wise
will do you in there was like oh yeah
just give me a you know tequila on the
rocks
and then they show up with a tequila
like this big and you're like i
appreciate it but also now
now this is my night right right exactly
it's funny because
they're your friend and they want to be
nice but they're also ruining your life
we've all had that we got we know you
don't you know the bartender at this
cool dive bar so they hook you up but
you're like if i drink that i'll
i'll [ __ ] out my liver but thank you
but thank you it's perfect uh so how
long are you coming back tomorrow
no no i can't leave i'm [ __ ] i did
this show
i added this show and then kill tony
hitchcliff was like you want to kill
tony tomorrow i was like all right [ __ ]
it
put down let's get another hotel room
for another night let's let's do it up
so i'll be back tuesday
nice but i just i appreciate you guys
making
making time for this in the day because
i knew right when you get out of this
theater you just hit the street and you
just guzzle
you guzzle booze and you yeah some guy
hands you a pill
and you start jerking off a guy and it's
all over
oh dude it's there's an energy in the
west village right now that's pretty
crazy like i was out with our boy
salaccus last night
yeah thank you he had such a good time
man i love him he's very
there was a great moment at the cellar
where i'm just hanging out with him on
wednesday there
and sean patton and louie come over and
they say what's up and uh
and sean pan goes oh you're salaccus
and he goes oh i love your work and uh
and louie goes oh what do you do and he
goes i'm a photographer and i and a
filmmaker and louis was like oh
louis like did a double take i think
he's like for him it was like a really
cool yeah
he's a film buff guy yeah and uh
it's funny you know that's amazing
celica don't know if you saw he had
this thing published in gq about
a crazy night he had with dmx who just
you know
all right by the way quick toast dmx
come on who doesn't [ __ ] we were
walking home last night salaccus and i
and we're on the train and we passed
some cops blasting
y'all gonna make me lose my cool and
you're like
talk about breaking through yeah
yeah crossover appeal jesus christ
but that's what this is that's what i oh
sorry sorry
this is what i like about dmx is uh i
mean sure we i mean i grew up with that
music it was big in high school what you
really want
[Music]
all that [ __ ] but dmx has a [ __ ] up
checkered past you know
some animal abuse some some domestic
whatever the hell it is
and we can still go yeah he wasn't
perfect he was a weirdo a psycho
but the music's great let's let the guy
die
it's all right and it's it's yeah he
also was like
i think he was a great actor honestly
like i remember there was a there was i
think a rolling stone or esquire article
back in the day
saying like yeah exit wounds isn't a
great movie but this dude has a [ __ ]
ton of talent
like this dude totally totally yeah
and you and you got to be a pretty good
actor to not be dragged down by steven
seagal
you know like he could i think like i
think good actors make you look better
so yeah you know but um
seinfeld said that's why he picked those
that cast because he was like don't pick
me up i mean it was just
you know costanza and elaine they're all
kramers just
talents so yeah the one of the best
casts of all time but uh
anyway sal excuses tell me stories about
dmx
and they're like so anyway he goes to
chicago
to photograph dmx writing xxl magazine
and he's in chicago and he's in the
hotel waiting for dmx
and he's like hey man uh he's talking to
the to the assistant like hey
where's dmx it's been four hours i'm
waiting and the assistant goes i'm gonna
be honest with you
he didn't make it to chicago
and he's like oh [ __ ] they're like
you know what i i feel bad i'll give you
his number so he calls him and dmx picks
up the phone it's like that raspy voice
he's like yeah yeah
and and sal accuses goes look man
i'm back in new york now i i really
wanted to photograph you in chicago i
i and dmx like i'm sorry all right all
right he goes where are you he goes i'm
in miami and he goes
if i come there tomorrow it's out of my
own pocket will you please
be there and he goes i'll pick you up at
the airport anyway
anyway he doesn't obviously he doesn't
pick him up but
but salaccus rents a car and he rolls up
to dmx's place and it's like he had just
had a newborn yeah so
they're hanging out now dmx is like he
said he's the nicest guy in the planet
he says yes to everybody
they are walking around did he freeze
oh no no oh god
holy that was good that was that was
some [ __ ] time
square let me just hold my pose level
good
yes yes but uh dude so
they end up going over doing all these
kinds of crazy [ __ ] they play pool
dmx takes all three games well he's not
even paying attention he's talking to
some artists
i'm an artist and he goes all right
let's record together and he just goes
to like record with her and
like talks over her track to like give
her extra you know it's like dmx is a
guest on my track now
they end up you know he's driving so
[ __ ] fast and south he's like this is
terrifying he has footage of the driving
he's like this is the scariest
like i'm wearing a seat belt and dmx is
like why are you wearing a seat belt
like if we flip this
the the seat belt might catch fire and
rust and you won't be able to get it off
and he's like you're thinking of
flipping a car
and then he's telling the story about
how they go to you know they go to
this tough part of miami and they end up
like buying drugs
and he's witnessing this and he's like
this is pretty crazy they end up in
some 7-eleven type you know bodega
whatever they're in the
7-eleven type store and these four kind
of
tough-looking kids are following around
and they go yo x where's the money at
oh like we're gonna get [ __ ] robbed
like this is terrifying
and they keep following around tmx kind
of ignoring them and he turns around and
goes
i was just about to rob you
[ __ ]
and they all laugh and high-five him and
he's just like he's just
kind of fearless wow he was that dude
and and yeah it's so you know damn cool
story that so if you uh just
just look up uh dmx gq if you want the
full story but it's pretty damn cool our
boy sally q is pretty pretty cool nod
great cat i love salaccus i mean what
did he look like in miami with dmx they
probably thought he was
his lawyer or publicist or something you
know this little white guy with a
with you know hawaiian shirt on
is our our creamer you know he's got
he's got a hawaiian shirt on he's got
wacky hair
he's he's like up for anything oh yeah
you're going to miami i'll go with you
you're going to bro
he's like shoot this but he's like dry
new yorker he's like a drier new york
type
he's like more of like a charles grodin
type of kramer
right right but i love guys like that
who are quiet they're kind of laid back
but they can also
spin a yarn where you're like what the
[ __ ] you've lived yeah
yeah well anyway this leads right into a
pet peeve of mine salary has told me
these stories
and i my peeve is drunks
whose energy overwhelm the room
yeah you hate the overwhelming because i
like having a drink with people but when
you when the drunks
so salicy's telling the story and
they're like oh yeah you're telling
literally
15 minutes of like them segwaying in a
[ __ ] about themselves
yeah and we're just sitting there like
i'm like at like minute 15 i'm like hey
i'd like to hear the story you know i
have to be that guy and i'm like i'd
like to hear the end of this
so then they're like all right all right
what and then and then he starts telling
the story again i go
he did what let me guess what happened
i'm like how could you just let him tell
the story
yes stop interjecting your queef jesus
isn't a [ __ ] choose your own
adventure
[ __ ] this is yeah this is this
is real life that's what i said and then
also a story's got a rhythm and like if
you keep [ __ ] with the rhythm it's
like
it's like we're taking a shower and you
keep flushing the toilet like the
temperature's going up and down like
just
let it happen come on i hate that
i'm so i'm so with you on that and then
they got to get their dumb joke in and
then you got to pretend to laugh at
their joke but you don't actually want
to hear the joke it's
it's like what is this chelsea lately
this is a dinner
let us tell the [ __ ] this is a panel
what were you at a house party where was
he telling the story no we're just we're
just
at a bar but uh okay you know whatever
well yeah that's i'm so with you on that
pet peeve just let the guy get the story
out then we can all
canoodle and chop it up about the story
after but let's
let's let it happen
i don't know if canoodle's the right
word
[Laughter]
yeah i double check kiss and cuddle
amorously
[Laughter]
but wait what'd you say i don't know we
canoodled afterwards we made our we
cuddled it was [ __ ] i was
so cute i was spooning him by the end it
was weird but uh how about
this one on the same vein as yours is
when you go i'm watching a comic or i'm
watching a concert
and you're like oh this guy's great i
gotta watch this guy
and they go okay i'll watch with you and
then they're going oh that was pretty
good
and i'm like i said i was gonna watch
this guy and now you're
interrupting even though i told you i
said i was gonna watch and you keep
interjecting with your [ __ ] point and
i'm trying to listen
yeah it's tough you gotta just give him
what the okay yeah yeah
yeah yeah you give them one ear yeah got
it and then you're really listening with
the other ear
yeah brutal yeah
my pet peeve this mine is weird and
super it's like complete minutiae
tiny slice of life [ __ ] but it
happens to be all the time
and it's when you're walking down the
sidewalk with a
with a friend or whatever and they keep
getting closer to you
and before you know it you're you're
kind of inching away and before you know
it you're on the lawn or you're in the
street
and you're like all right buddy and then
you switch to their other side and then
they do it again to you the other way
you ever have that brutal it's awful
yeah
it's like i'm i'm pigeon toed and i'm
still very aware of like hey man
come on yeah like they just they don't
it's subconscious and they just keep
kind of inching towards you so you inch
away and then before you know it you're
you're in a building i'll tell you what
i'm loving
i love space man i'm a big space guy you
know i picked down a city obviously but
i was at a like a
sidewalk cafe with my brother uh
yesterday
and all this out remember when
restaurant tables would be two inches
apart
and you'd be like this is not enough
space for me
especially with comics you know we're
going to say something horrible and
they're going to give us dirty looks you
know
so you have that little plastic guard
now it's kind of nice
oh yeah oh for sure yeah those that
i mean you grew up in in manhattan so i
i don't know how
i figured you'd be used to it but that
knows you never get used to it you never
get
fully used to it i also hate the other
table hearing my conversation i'm doing
20 minutes on puerto ricans and i'm like
can they hear this what if they filmed
me you know it's just it's so
i hate that feeling of like [ __ ] can you
believe uh
cuomo or whatever and yeah i don't know
i just hate them hearing
be hilarious if you got canceled for a
take on cuomo and cuomo did not get
cancelled
i know exactly that's that's where we're
at that would trump all the time look at
billy bush
that's a great point i have a point yeah
that is
damn yeah well cuomo's really like he's
doing it
it's getting to a point where i am
starting to enjoy it because he's just
like it does take a level of confidence
to just like to not even address the
allegations at this point
just like she'll be like what's going on
what's on the agenda today boys and
you're like oh you're just not even
gonna talk okay
all right goodness it's kind of
impressive
it is well the first couple you're like
oh damn this guy's a psycho he's in
trouble he's grabbing women and then i
read a few and they're like
he kissed my cheek he waved to me he
gave me an elbow
elbow bump i was like all right all
right come on
i don't i don't doubt that he's a shitty
boss and shitty person
but it is like now it's kind of like
when you when you kind of
give al frank in the boot i know he
resigned but he kind of got the boots
like this now he's
he's he's going to benefit from that
[ __ ] because you're like well he kind of
got [ __ ]
so yes so true so true but yeah that
space in new york i mean
even the grocery store the aisles you
like somebody else comes down the aisle
you're like oh [ __ ] you got to do this
the sideways shimmy that is not not made
for humans you gotta grab your partner
dosie doe it's [ __ ] horrible
you know i'm walking my brother down the
street this is a great new york moment
i'm wearing my brother
uh upper west side we passed the
sidewalk cafe and
as we walk by we overhear a woman she's
got the burger uh open face she hasn't
closed it yet
and she just goes to the way to a bird
[ __ ] on my burger
she's like she's asking for another
burger because it burns [ __ ] on a burger
that is classic wow which is kind of not
the restaurant's fault like i guess
that's the risk you run if you're
sitting outdoors but you gotta probably
give a free burger
you gotta do it yeah and the sad thing
is if if she would have closed that
without looking she would have eaten
that thing because it kind of could be
like a black and blue or uh
you know like blue cheeseburger if you
if you don't look at it directly
damn it's funny how outside eating used
to be such a treat like oh there's a
patio or ooh
let's eat outside you know the sun is
shining and now it's like
get me the [ __ ] roof give me an ac
give me a booth
give me inside it is it's so true it's
it's funny how uh everywhere in new york
it's like i get new york
doesn't give a [ __ ] about parking really
so i guess it's good for restaurants
because
let them make more money they got [ __ ]
for a year you know let them make
let them make the money and you know if
you have a car in new york i guess you
got to use a garage i don't know but
yeah uh for at least a while let them
make that money back
but hell yeah i'm telling you how bad
traffic gets
just because i feel guilty i'm like here
you go waiter i mean you got
[ __ ] hard yeah it's a it's
rough and then uh i do kind of like it
though it's like dirty it's like dirty
paris man it's kind of cool
yeah that's true that's true i guess
paris is kind of dirty too but
uh but new york you know it there are
certain areas that don't lend itself
to outdoor dining where you'll be
sitting there and it's like right next
to a hospital
and you're like i'm just going to hear a
siren all day right it's kind of rough
right
yeah that's true you hear in the
distance clear we're losing them
you're like i expected a i expected a
better ambiance from the firehouse cafe
this is [ __ ]
i love dirty paris by the way that's a
sex move if i ever heard it i gave her a
dirty ferris
[Laughter]
that's weird eiffel tower with a guy and
jizz on her ass i don't know
it is funny that anything will be turned
into a sex term at some point like
eiffel tower what
i know the most like beautiful pristine
sculpture in the world has turned into
like a threesome you know with two guys
high-fiving
i gave her a mona lisa whoo what's that
yeah fun fact about the mona lisa by the
way do you know the story behind that
what is it well this is what's so
interesting about showbiz and
entertainment like you know bill burr
great comic yada yada yada but he didn't
break until that philly rant
and that like kind of put him on the map
and he was always good but that put him
on the map
the mona lisa was just this kind of
run-of-the-mill
painting from italy and you know as
whatever people walk right by it every
day
then it got stolen became the talk of
the art world
every newspaper the mona lisa is stolen
some art thieves
they found it then they put it back and
now everybody had to see it because it
was the big stolen painting
so it almost kind of went viral
interesting it's da vinci right did he
not break till like
i always wonder i don't know enough
about art to know which artists like
they're like oh they they're huge and
and you know yeah
when you reminisce about them you're
like what were they [ __ ]
no were they huge at the time most of
them probably had nothing
i think he was some but he was kind of
like you know uh what's a good like he
was like roy wood jr to us
like oh he's [ __ ] killer he should be
way bigger household name but he's
he's just kind of like a working good
comic
that's how da vinci was all these guys
picasso apparently died penniless and
all these other guys
they always blow up later that's gonna
be like a tell
that's brutal i know i know yeah
especially if you die young man look at
all the people that die young bruce lee
jesus janice joplin
yeah so true hendricks yeah you're right
uh hendricks nirvana guy jamora
yeah cobain yeah is that the 27 club or
32 club
i believe cobain was 27.
and that jesus 32 or 33.
i think he was 33 yeah which every comic
would be like hey i'm 33. look if jesus
already did this and that i haven't even
gotten on conan
but yeah yeah mona lisa had to go viral
for because it is just a basic kind of
mediocre painting no offense it's good i
guess but it you needed that
that bump that was like the rogan bump
it's interesting it's like it isn't you
know what that was kind of cool is
i just think about what art used to be
and i know there's still
art and there's still great movies and
there's still
you know tv now is kind of like the new
medium right but
you think about like have we watched
bonnie and clyde
oh great movie it's so [ __ ] good it's
like a badass movie from the 60s you
know badass
gritty dark and it's it's uh i forgot
i don't want to say miss on send but i
went to watch it in film school and it's
it's shot like a like a foreign film
like the cuts and the angles and the
twists and the turns
the sharp whatever contrast that's all
that was all new back then
and they did it first yeah i i don't
know if i said this last week but it was
i think was supposed to be directed by
truffaut so it's like had and i was
supposed to be a good daughter and then
i'm gonna be an arthur penn but like man
it ends up being awesome and
yeah it was so hot it was like crazy
so hot so hot and and it was that was
like heavy stuff for what was that
early 60s i think 67 oh okay
but yeah that was that was a cool ass
movie still holds up still fun the
acting is great
love it yeah yeah oh yeah uh estelle
parsons
who was at a show of mine one she's like
90 something now yeah my parents knew
her somehow and they brought her to like
an early
caroline's breakout artist type show
and i was not good it was one of those
things where i'm like did i just [ __ ]
do very mediocre in front of a legend
you know
like this woman's like partied with
warren beatty and probably like jack
nicholson and i'm just like i'm like
so anyway my dick and it's just like
bombing
yeah yeah dude i i bombed in front of
marcia gay harden
oh lover man super milfie in person by
the way like yeah
and in a rubies yeah yeah for sure
but i you know you start bombing and
then when you start you start
kind of scrambling up there you just get
too real you're like what the hell are
you doing here we're all a bunch of
it was a horrible hack-filled lineup it
was at joe franklin's remember that
place
oh my god yeah when was it the 80s what
the hell
it's like 10 years ago it was like all
these horrible comics on the show and me
and i'm bombing they're bombing
can i switch spots with you i'm going to
catch a rising star at 11.
[Laughter]
right exactly so uh i had evening at the
improv in 20. so i had to run out of
there but
but uh i bombed it i was like what are
you doing here you're so hot you're
milfie and it took everything i had not
to make fun of the gay harden i mean it
was too
it was right there but i i i didn't do
it out of just
that would have only made it worse if
you really dressed her oh my god
i didn't do it you can't she's so she's
a good actress too
oh man that that's rough but i heard you
at least booked a
a guest spot on sanford and son out of
that so that's pretty cool
yeah yeah my family ties call back fell
through
but uh yeah yeah she was uh she was nice
and pretty and
that was a that was a bummer but i told
my mom about it she was like oh that's
cool i've heard of her
yeah dude she's great she's she's been
around man
oh yeah oh yeah i don't know what she
must have had a friend there
something was going on because i'm like
this is a divey grimy
midtown comedy spot in the back of a
restaurant
what the [ __ ] are you doing here so cool
so much cooler to see that type of actor
than
like an a-list person because there's
she's just like a more interest she
makes interesting choices and stuff
remember laura linney was a gotham one
so like that's a cool actress wow
that is cool she's good she's a great
actress
yeah she rules what's uh what's that
guy's name uh
not javier bardem what was the guy from
300 the hot guy
gerard butler butler he was at the fat
black one time and he's there all the
time he's tired
yeah oh that was crazy he's like three
feet away from me i'm like what are you
doing here it's me and
30 retards on this show and you're
you're sitting like in the first row
second row it was crazy
it is hilarious when you're like bombing
you're like [ __ ]
that the dude from that shitty katherine
heigl movie what the hell yeah
i know right yeah but you always hear
about the comedy store they were like
tarantino's here tonight i'm like what
the [ __ ] tarantino's here
that's like better that's a hot crap i
know you better hope that's a hot crowd
yeah i opened for a guy once not gonna
say who
but bieber was in the crowd and that was
pretty cool
oh my god that's weird yeah he walked
during my set
but either way i got to see him did he
really yeah
he was like this is nerd that's [ __ ]
hilarious
you walked bieber it's just cool like we
think oh new york it's home it's where
we live our apartment's tiny
uh you know i my hallway smells like
[ __ ]
my neighbor hates me but then you're
like oh yeah so does jennifer aniston
lives here whoever in in this city
it's crazy to thank all the celebs it's
just a real city man it's just a [ __ ]
cool it's like not it's i feel like
a new you know what's cool about new
york is like we still appreciate
that in la i feel like they don't even
appreciate they are like
like tarantino they'd be like oh okay
whatever you know i know
he's like one of my heroes and i used to
live on 10th street in the village and
sarah jessica parker lived
one block ahead of me and i would walk
by and every time i walked by i was like
maybe she'll come out today maybe i'll
see her today
but never did but i knew where she lived
that sounds weird i was looking at her
windows and
[Laughter]
that's a new york couple broderick and
sarah yes
both i think born and raised she might
be jersey actually
yeah our boy david jusko knew her pretty
well back in the day and
always says she was the coolest person
and yeah ryan hamilton knows her and and
says she's awesome
she did communes in cars and it was it
was i fell in love with her she was so
down to earth and everything good laugh
great laugh
great laugh great face i know a lot of
people think she's weird-looking but i'm
into it
that's your type yes
you like a mug yeah oh it's not like the
mug it's like the nose you look
like a bigger nose i think oh give me a
honker
all right what do we got speaking of
speaking of things we like
we might be drunk is brought to you by
honey
you gotta love honey you know we all
shop online we've all seen that empty
promo code
field just taunting you you know you buy
something online you go
oh look at that i can fill it in right
now but i don't know what it is and i
don't know how to get it
well thanks to honey you don't have to
search for one anymore
honey is a free browser extension that
scours the internet for just
discount codes when you're ready to
check out honey automatically applies
the best one
instant savings honey has found its
customers over two
billion clams in savings
supported by over 30 000 stores online
what a genius
invention this is i mean this is
brilliant you don't have to do anything
i used to always be like promo i would
google promo code for the store i was
shopping at yes yeah it does it for you
this does it for you
what's your go to normand order on like
on the internet what's up
i got shirts on my site or or you can
buy our albums uh somewhere no no i
meant like
what's something that you order is what
i mean oh oh oh well i don't want to
give any brands away but i i
i just got some jeans off the internet i
buy shoes online all the time
jeans i can't do i'm always scared
clothes i've done it and
i'm always disappointed with like it
rarely works but i i got lucky these
jeans fit like a glove it all worked out
but yeah i get all my
you know toilet paper toothpaste i get
all that [ __ ] online and uh it's
it's just so easy just shows up one day
so i highly recommend it my mom would
stand on the counter
at the counter at the grocery store
clipping coupons for half an hour with
everybody behind her pissed off
so this is the way to go tell them how
to do it sammy
uh yeah if you don't already have honey
you could you could be
missing out on free savings literally
free installs in just a few seconds
save some dough support this podcast get
honey for free at
joinhoney.com drunk
that's joining honey dot com slash drunk
get that honey baby oh yeah
nice honey yeah it's good it's a good
one
yeah yeah yeah i got to tell you i i
i've been traveling i've been doing
shows been writing i don't have uh
a recommendation per se yeah but i do
have to say i bought a watch
and i love it it's the best thing i've
ever bought myself what is it let me see
well it's nothing snazzy i got a oh [ __ ]
i got a timex it's a vintage look it's
only 50 bucks timex but it's
it's the best watch i've ever had it
fits right on it's that kind of cool
uh oh look at that like the band is just
there's no clip it just kind of
sucks on your wrist and uh it's got the
indigo light
it's got the date the day of the week
and the time that's all i need
never been a big watch guy i wasn't
either and i tried it now
it's all i do is every day just look at
this you never have to pull your phone
out you got the watch right there
i knew a kid playing basketball grew up
who had a watch and it was like sharp
on the oh yeah and he would like try to
swipe you with it you're supposed to
take the watch off and like i mean
you're cutting me dude he was like
that's how he would like try to [ __ ]
intimidate you on defense
oh what a douche that's evil it was it
was [ __ ] evil
it was an evil [ __ ] yeah that
but no this is just
i learned on stage and you just kind of
look at your phone but on 20 minutes
i've been on 30 minutes i mean it's
it's a huge game changer for me i like
knowing what time it is all the time
it's nice to know that not to look at
your phone for just another reason to
not look at your phone so that that is
cool
yeah i read some stat that we open our
phones like 600 times a day
over over a day and you're like ah i
can't have that
that ain't good no and and how many
times do you go oh i got a text
john and then you open your phone you
didn't even text now you're on twitter
now you're on instagram now you're on
facebook now you're on email you didn't
even get to the text
yeah it's terrible man it really is and
like it's it can't all the things that
we we talk about how we need our brains
and then you just feel your brain turn
it into mush
and uh i like we're doing on a drinking
podcast you got to take care of your
brain i'm like literally
right like [ __ ] it i hobbled out of bed
at 1 15.
uh i'm like you got to take care of
yourself folks
uh anyway yeah i got a good wreck
i think oh hit me i already said it's
bonnie and clyde man i like
there's movies from the 60s you know
what i like about and
all right spoiler if you haven't seen it
but something i like about
60s movies is they would just end in
[ __ ] up ways yeah something really
cool 70s did this too but like
i mean dog day afternoon yeah taxi
driver they could just do something
shocking and then the credits roll
right totally i kind of love that i mean
you know what's coming you know they're
gonna die
but uh yeah you don't know when
yes yeah that's so true yeah the
70s i think is the best decade for film
because it it didn't get as uh
commercialized and like corporate and it
was just art
like cuckoo's nest is art that is a
[ __ ]
film it's gritty and weird and twisted
and
funny sweet funny it's got everything
right
yeah there's two the loving these kind
of they kind of hit they kind of hit
every you know it's also funny when
bonnie and clyde came out jack nicholson
was like nobody right i mean
he was not famous not really no he was
just the young
kind of hot young guy who just killed it
was like chinatown and cuckoo's nest and
five easy pieces an easy rider easy
rider 69 though that wasn't even out i
wonder when five easy pieces came in i'm
looking it up
i'm gonna go 72.73 70.
so here to run and then chinatown man
faye dunaway the fact that she's in
chinatown
network and bonnie and clyde is like
that's like first battle
hall of fame [ __ ] that's totally what a
roster what a resume
yeah she is she is so hot and and cool
and kind of
sophisticated even just
[ __ ] up in the head right even even
back in like the 80s
70s 80s like animal house caddyshack the
comedies
were still solid movies like ferris
bueller's day off
is a movie i grew up with and it's
actually a good movie and it's a comedy
or or
breakfast club or home alone all those
you know i don't know how good home
alone is i like it but i don't know if
it's like a great movie i mean it's not
it's not the godfather
hold on
do you like it no hormone 2 is a pile of
garbage
it's terrible one is one has got the
it's got the heart i get it but you're
like this [ __ ] come on like pesci and
stern they were so good
yeah pesci pesci just never missed it
was never
never misses even eight heads in a
duffel bag had moments
yeah i remember that movie
remember that [ __ ] awful uh poster
too but yeah they've gone fishing i saw
all the [ __ ]
uh god fishing uh
but my cousin vinnie good movie i mean
look it's a
great movie yeah it's not cool and luke
but like that is a great movie trading
places
uh coming to america all those land of
blues brothers is good
like even the comedies were fun good
movies now it just feels like
cheaper by the dozen parent trap
uh all this [ __ ] i was like come on you
know why dude because
it's all about excess now it's like
algorithm [ __ ] i mean it's
what it literally is an algorithm it's
like let's totally like you hear all
about like
multi-picture deals back in the day but
they
still took time on that [ __ ] i feel like
everything's rushed out now
and that's what like tick tock and all
that [ __ ] is and that's why when you see
a movie like bonnie and clyde you're
like
this took years to make yes you felt
that it was like important like you
could just tell like you know warren
beatty produced to be like oh you could
just sense like he cared about this
material and
you know the riders forever to to get it
sold and it's kind of it's kind of cool
it's a cool story you know it's really
cool even cars i mean not to get into
cars but like you see a car from the 70s
or the 60s you're like it's this
beautiful with these great lines and
curves and
they didn't think about crumple zones
and airbags obviously so you know
everybody died but
i mean they're just so cool and you look
at every car now and it's like it just
looks like a you know a [ __ ]
shopping cart with wheels and a roof
well you have a classic car i mean like
something cool about about classic about
throwback i mean i mean yeah
now there is yeah i mean you're right
there
are no airbags in some of these cars
but there is something pretty damn cool
about it still
i think it's a lot like comedy like
we'll sacrifice
you know we'll say some darker stuff or
go in some twisted areas
because we don't have airbags we got
we gotta we want the art we want the
bonnie and cloud we want the
old beamer we want our comedy to be
this stylized thing and that you work
hard on it like your special
list special my special great views
because i think people can see that
there's some blood sweat and jizz in
there
yeah you got to put work into it man
it's like that's what the road is for
some people like man it's got to be hard
to do the road but that's what it's for
is to
yeah own them it's to hone the material
and like dude we
we're the only types of entertainers
that like focus group our [ __ ]
yeah you think about that like we're
taking it like let's see how toledo
responds to this
let's see how minneapolis responds to
this you know so
good point yeah i mean it's necessary
it's a necessary part of the the gig to
take it different places and
you know maybe sometimes one market
doesn't respond but hopefully you
i think overall you're like i think i
know what works right
and and not only do we focus group it
but we focus group it and write it and
perform it so it's
all filtered through us at the end of
the day whereas
a movie or tv show they go ah we showed
it to a few housewives in minneapolis
and they didn't like that guy so we got
to get rid of him you're like yeah but
he's the bad guy you're not supposed to
like i know but he's unlikable get rid
of them
so now you got eight people telling you
this it's a film about hitler
yeah exactly this fat lady in milwaukee
didn't like the hitler characters so we
gotta we gotta cut him out of the movie
she found him to be toxic and we have to
remove hitler
no it's you're so right man it's like
you're focus
at least you're focused grouping it
mostly for people that came out to see
you on them yes right
so whereas like movies and tv sometimes
you're like yeah this person might not
like it you're like well that person is
not the right demo
that's they shouldn't like it yes
exactly not everyone should like
you know you ever see a movie with like
88 on ron tomatoes you're like that's a
good number
i don't want a [ __ ] nine i don't want
a 99 or 100
point it's like these [ __ ] with the uh
with the the zagget and this yelp they
go
how'd you like that sushi restaurant ah
i gave it one star i hated it zero
percent you go
geez zero percent they go well i don't
like sushi well then you shouldn't be
rating it
what are you doing if you don't like
sushi to begin with why are you reading
a sushi restaurant i don't know
those are the best reviews i don't like
i don't like the thing that they do
yeah yeah so the whole restaurant sucks
no you just don't like it
oh people are [ __ ] trash they're nice
they're dumb because just me me me i
don't like it so it must be bad well
i i don't like isis but isis is happy to
be in there
people people vary jp
jp mcdade has a joke about uh how the
you can google review the great wall of
china and it's four stars
uh and then he goes to give you uh
an example uh he kisses some shitty
restaurant in florida
that's 4.3 stars it's like
such a great observation oh yeah people
are such
we're [ __ ] in grades we really are
all of us
it's set and yet we want their approval
at the end of the day which is
uh which is the real rub of it all but
that's why comment cards at clubs you
ever starting out and you get like the
comment cards you're just like
who leaves i mean i guess some people
leave good [ __ ] on common cards but the
people that are really
taking them seriously they
ain't they ain't helping no no
definitely not like
i would we would get drunk at the club
sometimes and like i'd watch the staff
clean up and they're all mopping and
sweeping and
we'd take the bucket out we'd have a
couple of drinks start reading them
as a goof and you know
they were every funny here's my number
here's my email not a bad show
chicken wings were cold where's fluffy
bringing fluffy i want russell peters
angela johnson he was okay the curly
haired guy wasn't bad
bringing uh jim jeffries like all right
what do we do we would just laugh all
night reading those
it was no jeff dunham i'm like damn all
right yeah thanks
uh yeah i know they they uh they really
go to they really go to town
it is funny when that you see someone
you're like the feature was better the
opening act was better and you're like
this i'm holding onto these these are
[ __ ] hilarious oh yeah oh yeah i
i think i pocketed a few great ones too
like nice guy
i wish you'd admit he was gay and you're
like all right what does that have to do
with the app that's [ __ ] great
yeah that's a great one i got a lot of
those
yeah i [ __ ] clubs that are still doing
that it's like [ __ ]
nice it was youtube comments before
youtube you're right
hand-written youtube comments
hand-written youtube
may as well have a [ __ ] an ink a
quill and a [ __ ] ink pen
yeah exactly but i don't know apparently
club bookers read those or they used to
i think they read those if you're like a
brand new headliner or something
yeah like we want to see if we'll bring
them back how about a
kevin hart back in the day i'm talking
like late 90s
would do a show stand outside the club
door
with a composition book say thank you to
everybody and get their email
back when email was new and exciting and
then he would email
everyone and then do a mailing list that
when he came back to philly or
denver he would he would email him
brutal but
you know what i mean i respect him so
much for doing that even though it's
brutal
i also heard that back in the day his uh
his travel budget was like five thousand
dollars because they had to take care of
his entourage
this one he was like a young headliner
too it's [ __ ] hilarious
what is that i mean he had a crew i mean
i think it was like i want to take care
of my people it's like and he wasn't
making like that much more than that so
it's just hilarious that he was
that but he i probably just knew he was
going to make it i think he was just
that driven
yeah i guess so jesus christ i tried
doing that a couple shows with the
composition pad and then it's like
people are drunk you're like trying to
decipher
you're like is that an eight or a zero
and then you're like i'm drunk it's 2
a.m i'm
manually putting these into my computer
what the [ __ ] wrong with me you know
right
right and on paper it sounds easy you
bump into people you get their email
case closed but it's actually a full
conversation then they critiqued your
act and then they tell you how much they
hate
your co-host and it goes on from there
it's the worst in the words of uh
albert brooks the complisalt have you
heard of that
the complex salt that's yeah that's
where it's everything starts out as a
compliment but if you wait long enough
it'll turn into an insult like
i thought you were an assault i thought
you were going to saw it that's funny
too
but you're like i loved your act man
yourself my wife hates you
she hates you but i love you you know if
you stay long enough it'll get mean
i thought you were funny i thought you
were good i don't know what
it went well why are you talking to me
like this i thought you were good
right right exactly i killed i thought
yeah i was the one laughing like it went
well why are you talking to me like this
stop it yeah yeah you ever uh
you ever had that thing this is rare but
it happens the other way sometimes where
you walk off stage you're like man i
suck that crowd hated me
i gotta i gotta write more i gotta fix
that i gotta do this and then you listen
to it it sounds pretty good
yeah it's like the opposite of laugh
ears right where you're like yeah
some people some people eat [ __ ] and
they get off like
nothing is wrong and then other people
i guess i think i did that the other
night the seller actually i was like
that was [ __ ] brutal i was listening
to this i was like oh it's pretty good
this
one pretty well yeah yeah like poor
jokes so i was like yeah that's pretty
good
especially hard on new joe i or at least
i am i'll do i'll throw a new one out
there and it's all risky and scary and
you're like oh they hated it that joke
sucks i'm not good writer
and then you listen to it you're like oh
no that did okay
yeah i do the same i mean i because you
they're they're trying out for the team
essentially
yes exactly and you're kind of like
you're better you better impress yeah
you don't want the new guy who come in
and [ __ ]
just bend over yeah you can't hang with
these other jokes
yeah yeah i remember one time i saw a
comic we both loved
great comic and he bombed on this bar
show
and all these comics came up to me like
you did better than that guy he's he's
the name and you're not and da da
and i'm like he did all new [ __ ] all
those premises were gold
in a week those are going to be you know
closers
so that's he's doing it right i'm not a
fan of the
comparing the i hate the show it's like
guess what
even if i don't even if i don't like
love the guy
i still like feel like an obligation a
little bit to defend yes
you know it's something and yeah i don't
like the pittiness against each other
that's what the [ __ ] industry does
dude
they put us against each other like we
we're the ones who help each other out
like who who helps you more than comics
of course it's all comics definitely
for sure but i do watch you know when
it's a
like what do you call a showcase show at
the seller the six comics and a host or
five comics and a host
you watch everyone come out of there and
if you listen they're going the third
guy was the best
i liked the ford guy fourth fifth guy he
was the best one you're like
this is what everybody does you're like
just enjoy it it's but it's like a human
nature
thing you just have to rank people they
like um
that's why people like reality shows
because there's a winner it's so stupid
but you know that's not how i consume
stuff really you know
i don't watch a movie and i'm like i'm
like i'm watching
i'm watching bonnie clyde's shame like
man this is a [ __ ] great cast that's
what comes to my mind
yeah yeah man this is so well shot it's
not like i'm not like watching like faye
dunaway was better than warren beatty
i'm just like they're both [ __ ] good
i don't know i don't
i'm not trying to it's weird it's a
weird way to
uh i don't know it's a weird way to look
at things but it's almost
it's just subconscious because we all do
it he stole the show i mean
he was the breakout star she really
really
took the thunder or whatever it is you
know i'm sure i've done it a bunch but
it's
i don't i try not to do yeah well i mean
look it's such a
competition obsessed culture i mean it's
why people love
right sports and and things like that i
mean there's
there is a winner it is a story it is
it's it's meant to inspire
and not just entertain but people like
this person
it's like an underdog story that's they
call it a cinderella story yeah
you know it's like people are obsessed
with they are
losing you know it's and then the the
irony is that you make it to the top
the underdog made it and then they want
you to fail sure you know you right when
you get up there they're like all right
let's bring it back down you're like
what we just
traveled all the way up here it took 20
years and now you want me to come
crashing down
oh no that's that's why we built you up
to bring you back that way that's right
yeah for sure that's why i'm staying in
the middle i'm getting to the middle of
the mountain and i'm gonna
build a hut and get a couple chickens
and just hang out there
well they still want to bring you down
they'll just bring you even lower if you
stay in the middle
yeah yeah exactly i don't know i'm
getting one of those weird
hammock things on the side of the
mountain that just hangs there and you
can sit in it and
take photos and have a coffee out of a
thermos i think
i think it's basically that is
a showbiz career basically it's like
yeah but
yeah but i mean that was like sinatra
right i mean yeah i think it's possible
and then he's like [ __ ] people forget
him then
from here to eternity then he's back and
then you're like right oh [ __ ] his
entire life was kind of up and down it
was it was a higher up
and a higher down yeah you know yes
but it was you know but
patrice said it best i think he said
show business is a roller coaster you
wait in line
then you notice hey i'm ticking up we
got we're going up this is great this is
fun then you're on top you're like oh
[ __ ] i'm on the top of the loop this is
crazy and then
then you wait in line again just for
that one little rise
but you're gonna fall it's a perfect
analogy
that's what a drug is you there is a
higher chasing that's kind of like kind
of a comedy it's kind of how you stay as
a stand-up because
you kind of get one taste early on of a
good set
be it a bringer show or maybe you just
got you got a hot crowd at the right
time and
you get just enough to be like all right
i'm gonna i'm gonna stick around but
and you are chasing that high it is a
drug
totally i mean how many people in comedy
are like that guy's still doing it i've
never seen that guy do well i've never
seen him happy with a set the crowd
hates him
20 years later still doing it because he
can still he still gets the
accoutrements
you know you still get a oh i guess i
got a show tonight oh oh
what do you do i'm a comedian oh my
profile's me with a microphone you still
get all the fun stuff even though
the eight minutes of bombing sucks and
you'll never make it but you still get
those other things
any uh person probably also had a good
set like three months ago
right if they're getting up enough like
as we say if you do enough sets you're
gonna have the horrible sets
right so if you do enough sets you're
gonna have those [ __ ] kill sets even
if you're not that good some crowds are
just
red-hot that's true that and they go
that crowd got it
those other crowds are idiots that one
that one got me
you're like yeah that makes sense i i
did that [ __ ] for years
all right we all did you know you had to
lie to yourself in the beginning we all
sucked
yeah it's always when there's people
that kind of just come out of the gate i
think i heard billboard once say you
know
uh that comics will post their early
sets and like how stupid that is because
because like you think de niro posted
like his first acting audition
uh right right but we'll do that with
stand up it's like oh you'll show
yourself as weak
yeah it's true but it's also in
in the context of look how much better
i've gotten and look how bad i used to
be
people can progress so i think it's cool
i saw
john goodman posted his roseanne
audition and it was killer you're like i
would have hired him too
i think i don't think there was ever a
time when he was bad though
i like can't picture john goodman not
being
he's [ __ ] great he's a beast he's
great and everything big lebowski he's
great roseanne he was great i mean he
was
king ralph the babe come on fred
flintstone
wonderful yeah what was it
inside lou and davis oh yeah wow
yeah no he's always great i love him
yeah flight he's good in flight
oh yeah he's he's a great actor um
great actor he's a weird new orleans
staple everybody in new orleans he has a
house down there he's like a big i saw
him in the street there once
shut up he was walking into a whole
foods i was like oh [ __ ]
it was when he was in a period where i
think he lost a good amount of weight
well yeah he's at whole food he's trying
to do something yeah
wow yeah you know he's a legend
oh yeah oh yeah and kind of keeps under
the radar you don't see him at like
big events and oscar [ __ ] you know he's
just doing his thing
for sure you got a new bit you're
working on
yeah i got a couple and uh they're all
over the place
they're so raw and loosey-goosey i've
been trying to find them on stage and
there's not enough there yet i need some
some heart a few loosey gooses as well
all right great i i got
two they're so loose that i feel like i
had to bring two because
they're not punched out yet but uh one
of them
is people keep complaining about a.i
like the beginning of the bit is uh it's
weird how technology keeps getting
better like everything's getting faster
and sharper and clearer and yet it feels
like people are getting worse
technology is getting better people are
getting more petty more narcissistic
more uh you know self-involved but
technology we got like an air fryer we
got streaming video
we're going to the moon all the time you
know it's like
everything we're making is getting
better but everything we make is getting
better except the people we're making
that's a good angle i had it's a
different bit i hit a bit of premise
once a long time ago i never really did
anything with it
but i had to say well how phones are
getting
better and people are getting worse and
i say yeah the phones are getting
thinner
you know ah that's good i never did
anything with it but there's something
about like yeah
i also think it's the technology making
us
worse oh that's interesting
because where are people at their worst
it's
i i think it's they're either on social
media or
or if they're in public what do you do
you put up a phone
yeah i mean no matter what
the technology surrounds us and it's a
part of the evil like people were [ __ ]
up before this [ __ ]
but this is like [ __ ] up enhancement
kinda
yes that might be the angle the
the technology is getting better and yet
it's making us
shittier and we make the technology
that's the irony
yeah we make it might be it let me write
that down
it's hurting our development and who's
making it kids
and hey right and and they're not even
developed yet
yes that's that's nothing but i'm just
riffing here but like
you know uh yeah it is making us worse
well then because you know what it's
it's it's an instinct
but then it's also kind of permanent
right like you have a couple drinks and
you're like i'm gonna tweet this
[ __ ] but then it's just up there that
was how you felt for like one moment
right now it's just now it's like like
this is how he feels in general
yes and you're like no that's how i felt
there's no there's no this is how i feel
in this particular moment setting for
twitter
right yeah it's true i mean how many
times have you gotten in a fight with
your mom go i hate you mom
you don't actually hate your mom and she
knows that but you just
in that moment you're so angry that you
you were irrational
i've never done that because i love my
mother yeah no of course i've done it
when you're a kid of course you do that
[ __ ] and
it's like yeah no you say that you say
[ __ ] you don't mean
i feel like therapy for both of us has
made us calmer in fights
yes don't you think oh for sure yeah
i've i've been pushing therapy on
everybody because you realize hey
some of this is on you buddy it's not
just other people being [ __ ] up
your god you've got some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
and that's what therapy's good for
yeah so good for the rest of that bit is
like
i can't wait for ai if you're like ai's
taking our jobs it's going to come in
and replace us i'm like
oh great somebody without a hot take who
does their job without complaining
that sounds amazing but is that too mean
i'm thinking it's like
it's not hitting so well it's tough
because
i i wonder why it might be like ai it's
like
well more people are going to be out of
work like it's going to [ __ ] yeah
that's why but like so with that take i
think you got to go further like i think
you got to go even harder with it
i think with a premise that's kind of
like you all [ __ ] we all suck ai will
be better
maybe you bring it on yourself and
you're like [ __ ] aha you know he's like
oh you know what i want this and my
agreement i want that in the dreamers
like oh you know what doesn't want that
robot mark normand and you're like oh
come on i'm basically a robot i bail
i barely feel
[Applause]
right right yeah yeah i don't want to
get a boner in a playground and don't
worry the ai won't
this robot he's going to keep it clean i
think you pulled on taking your job and
that'd be good too i think that would
make it interesting
because then i think bring it back on
you but yeah it's something about like
it's funny i do think about that
sometimes with like these these
conditions
in amazon warehouses are unlivable
they're unacceptable and you're just
like
you know some of these like people are
pregnant in the warehouses and you're
like well you know who won't get
pregnant as a robot
exactly and that's a [ __ ] heartless
horrible take but it's kind of funny
it's kind of funny and kind of true yeah
but obviously everybody needs a job but
uh yeah yeah
and truckers that's like a real like
that's a real word
that's a worry like jobs like that we
were like [ __ ] there's a lot of jobs
i mean we might get [ __ ] they keep
developing this hologram technology
it's like who do you want to see mark
norman samuel on the road or do you want
to see [ __ ]
uh george carlin live at the improv
you know beamed in yeah and even if they
do see our hologram he won't be hungover
he won't be trying new [ __ ] you know
he'll be a [ __ ] professional playing
the hits
yeah yeah
so that was that then then i have a
horrible premise about uh i'd be the
worst trans person because like trans
people have to be strong and like stand
up for themselves like hey it's not he
it's she
but if you call me matt i just go with
it
yeah you know i have no backbone with
that [ __ ] you're like hey
matt uh you're an improv guy right oh
yeah yeah that's me like i don't
it says ten dollars on the window you
you charge me 20 i just go
what it is when you when you aren't
trans
you take your identity for granted
because like someone says to me like
like seth i'm like yeah i could be a
seth who gives a [ __ ] you know what i
mean
whatever i'm like no it's actually sam
it's like you said to a trans person you
go
i'm veronica right right like
with me i'm just like yeah it's [ __ ]
i don't give i don't feel like
correcting them whatever well i think to
be trans yeah you got to have some
self-esteem you got to believe in
yourself a little bit
but uh me i'm just like oh i don't care
and also they are correcting people more
than
you are yes yes so they're used to
they're like that's kind of just like
reflex probably like no
actually i'm this okay right right my
apologies
yeah so that that was all i had on that
but uh what do you got
um i have a couple ideas so i was
watching that q and on doc which is
great i finished it loved it
uh oh yeah but i want to do i did a
thing about how like you know
one of cubanon's big thing is that
they're anti uh pedophile on
like wow what a brave stance to be
against pedophilia i've never met
i've met so few people that are like i
don't uh condone that
so very cool but to me it's like
uh i saw one sign in the video and it
said
pedophilia is not a sexual orientation
and you're just like
i've never heard that argument ever i've
never heard anyone
it's never like you're straight and
you're like actually a pedophile
that's how i identify i'm a child
molester and you're like so
yeah i don't know where to take it or
something about like hey go mom dad
sit down and we're like oh are you gay
and you're like a little a little
different
let me get into detail here like i don't
know how to end this but like yeah
yeah i like the idea of someone sitting
down their parents and be like mom dad i
am a i'm a pedophile
i hope i have your support yeah
something like that i don't know how to
like of course it's not a sexual
orientation it's the dumbest [ __ ] ever
but
maybe the only time pedophiles identify
as being a pedophile is when they have
to do the knocking in the neighborhood
and they go hey i'm just letting you
know i'm a sex offender you know that's
the only time they'll actually admit it
publicly yes something like when it's
when it's by law that's the only time
they'll say it
right right otherwise knocking the door
in a funny visual for sure that's good
yeah
also you know pedophiles are horrific
when even
murderers in prison are like we got to
beat up that guy if he diddled a kid you
know we got to kill him in the shower
i'm like you murdered your dad yeah yeah
he had it coming but that kid
or that guy touched a cub scout
we gotta kill him yeah that's funny yeah
even [ __ ] even murderers are like
this guy's gotta go well well they do
that they do that with everybody they do
it with regular people too but
right we really okay you kill regular
people through the air but this one's
personal we gotta really
yeah yeah exactly that's that's
if i was a pedophile i'd be in prison
like dude you you killed your sister
like
you killed a kid i [ __ ] one what's
worse
right there's the and the other angle i
had
i was watching the derrick uh show in
case the guy who killed george floyd
i don't know how you could watch that
[ __ ] it's horrific i mean just i'm out
of curiosity and to see how the lawyers
handle it really more
than anything but um
yeah i mean it's horrible it's like the
footage the worst thing i've ever seen
in my life
and i'm watching and i'm watching and
it's like makes you realize how much you
have to dumb down
a case for a jury so like our next uh
testimony is from a breathing expert
and uh some guy like sits down he's like
yes uh oxygen is is necessary
to uh and they're just like uh-huh and
you're you're sure about this you're
like yes i'm a breathing expert like all
right
and then uh i wanna do something like
like every person they bring in it's
like it's like you're explaining it to a
four-year-old it's
uh uh our next uh our police our police
chief
is coming in here uh it's our police
chief
and uh is this the normal protocol
for the minneapolis police and they're
like no not this was unacceptable and
they're like a condemnation
do you expect him to say right yes this
is our bread and butter
is uh chokeholds and ending fatalities
kind of what we do
kind of kind of like what what do you
expect
yeah yeah i like i don't know where i'm
going with this but there's stuff like
the idea that you just bring in people
and you're just like
yeah i you know i eat dinner every day
i'm kind of a foodie
yeah i was like the chokehold thing
expert
what i thought tried to do this a bit
but i never actually
did it on stage but it could be
something like why are cops talking
about these choke holds and [ __ ]
every cop car should have an mma referee
in it
you know so he could go like whoa oh
he's had enough you know like he knows
every uh every time like it's getting
serious that's their whole job is to
stop fights before they get too
dangerous
and that would be great to have with
cops yeah instead of a partner
instead of a partner they should have a
referee yeah because they know
everything about the body and choke
holds and all that [ __ ] they're like
ex-fighters so
who better to follow a cop around and go
okay
he's had enough you know that's good
that's funny
i think that could hit i could never uh
i'd never get anything with it
i don't think i don't know if i could
pull it off we'll see but that's
hard man the breathing thing is great
i'm an expert i'm an expert you need
oxygen i don't know if people know that
i don't know that's common knowledge but
uh that'd be funny if you made everybody
in the uh
in the jury like all right hold your
breath i'm gonna show you
i like it but that's you got good stuff
cooking
uh make sure to email us at we might be
drunk pod
yes gmail.com make sure to hit up the
patreon
oh yeah yeah keep listening this is a
fun pod man
good pod good up for for a couple of
hungover uh weirdos
i think we pulled out some some fun
facts some some interesting convo
send us your peeves i need some wrecks
i'm running out of [ __ ] to watch i've
watched every goddamn thing on uh
on the internet so uh send us all that
stuff send us some cocktails some drinks
fireside
shout out to you guys for sending that
those mixers and uh
yeah keep them coming thanks for
listening guys
tell a friend comedy